oh hi holy [ __ ] we're playing this [ __ ]
I thought I couldn't find it worst game
that sharknado but I think we might hit
the mother lode that loading what is
this the new PlayStation what do you
need to load like its of paint images
apparently what's even worse is that she
made like literally millions of this
game yes
as his loading bar takes forever I just
get more and more time to reflect on my
life and my choices so far I think
that's why they made it so short they
just be like are you really sure you
want to play this game didn't think you
could get slower but I was wrong again
holy [ __ ] do we actually get no it has
to load again oh my god holy [ __ ] we can
actually play are you serious you need
to refold some shirts okay so this is me
apparently oh God
don't wink at myself please it's telling
me to swipe here I'm swiping but it's
not really to win anything there we go
fold it and that gives me money and fame
apparently that makes so much sense holy
[ __ ] and lock the register really a
tough job I have here leave it so chic I
won't get so chic oh my god is Kim
Kardashian oh my god we still okay
please come in Kim K collect all the
star points why do I have to keep
clicking money like I don't understand
hey hey
then I just love it up I need you need
something cute but super quick where my
butthole it's pretty cute and super
quick no charge I want to charge her I
don't even get you I don't even get to
choose what's the point come to what
fine I'll come yes can't [ __ ] wait if
anything she can afford the paying for
her own clothes alright alright we need
to go to our apartment I don't know how
you do that so chic right now oh my god
Kim K you ain't getting my dollar
[ __ ] alright now we can take the metro
to Beverly Hills but we have to pay
in game money for it oh my god pressure
sorry I forgot to say your name was my
name is my anus my anus right I'm
getting it sank leg well I'll set two
for the shoot up so I got her free
clothes and now she wants to do a photo
shoot well I gotta check my makeup now
[ __ ] you I would not change you myself
or anyone who is he taking pictures of
right now I'm standing over there what
the [ __ ] he thinks I'm a ghost I wasn't
even in the pictures okay can I get the
[ __ ] out of here now oh who the [ __ ] are
you [ __ ] you
well thanks for nothing you piece of
[ __ ] all right we need to go to
Hollywood my anus I'm glad I ran into
you
oh stop it I need you to come and work
again tonight okay
hey hey get out of my way I'm trying to
fix fixture of salon ah ah
am I not famous enough oh I'm sorry oh
my god
step with the side I mean Pam knows
maybe someday you'll have your own show
- I can't I can't believe I saw Kim
Kardashian good for you good for you yes
I can Canadian good for you good for you
good for you get you and good for you
good for you good for you good for you I
only date models go to the CTN
management and get for you I'm a [ __ ]
gun who the F do you think you are f
pardon uh so what if I did leave quietly
hashtag [ __ ] where's the CTM management
[ __ ] it's supposed to be next there it
is alright there we go
how convenient you must be my anus oh
stop it I'm black and attractive but you
take me on Wow I don't know why not
alright that's cool complete photo shoot
for headshots of pop claim oh my god
what the [ __ ] was that it's such a
[ __ ] cat meow why am I like doing
here
job checking all this [ __ ] and why do I
get paid for it
am I like delusional I'm like actually
his assistant but I think I'm a model or
some [ __ ] what's with this [ __ ]
ambience noise like what the [ __ ] is
that it's not even a camera flash noise
cuz they did not bother doing that how
do I complete this [ __ ] [ __ ] oh my
god I leveled up oh my god I get what is
this now this is like mmo's for rich
young teenage girls I get it it's genius
really enjoying the game rate this game
so we can keep free updates coming yes
because obviously you're not making any
money out of this how do I write my
review there we go so far there hasn't
been enough title this point dead yes
that's how you spell it
ha in your face Kim K log on to Facebook
how about later
how about [ __ ] never oh my god Kim K
is calling shut up shut up Kim K's
calling me sounds good I'll gladly suck
your dick Kim K the dad was Kim K [ __ ]
hey what is your opinion about this this
game made millions so obviously people
are enjoying it right I just don't
understand it it's not for me but now I
played it so now we can move on with our
lives thank you for liking and
commenting on my anus
and I'll see you tomorrow with another
stuff love you brothers stay awesome my
finished